profil mais pour commencer deux
tourtereaux nous on s'aime et ça fait
cinquante quatre ans que cela dure
il pourrait chanter d'ailleurs madeleine
renaud et jean louis barrault reçoivent
un prix dont le seul nom vous expliquera
tout le prix amour toujours oui sa
maison tous une passion commune celle du
théâtre renaud-barrault on associe
forcément leurs deux noms ils sont
devenus le symbole de l' enthousiasme
jean-claude haricots je vous remet le
prix madeleine si je tiens à vous
embrasser aussi sur lui au couple
réussie qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un couple qui n'a pas cessé de 6
me depuis le premier jour ils se sont
rencontrés
l'amour c'est la vie quotidienne ou
c'est l'émerveillement permanent et de
13 heures nous nous devons de sens à la
fois les deux espèces d'émerveillement
permanent oui en effet mais ça paraît
naturel
7 c'est le bon dieu qui veut ça si on
vous demandait qu'est ce que vous
admirez qu'est ce que vous aimez le plus
chez madeleine qu'est ce que vous diriez
je ne tiens pas sa patience avec moi et
vous pas de vue qu'est ce que vous aimez
le plus ce genre l'oubli c'est très
grande humanité
ça c'est très rare ils se sont aimés 54
ans il s'en émerveille encore bravo
madeleine bravo jean lui bon
anniversaire et que ça dure encore
longtemps